[Musique]
et bienvenue pour un nouveau numéro du
débrief du doc on poursuit ce plongeon
dans la culture chamanique dans le
sillage du documentaire devenir chamane
diffusé sur notre antenne mais aussi sur
notre site est référencé point tvl
natalia cadijo va s'est donc rendue pour
rt en mauritanie à la rencontre des
chamans sibérien alors pour revenir sur
ce documentaire creuser encore un peu
plus cette culture chamanique comprendre
quelles leçons elle peut également
apporter à nos cultures occidentales
nous sommes avec charles la steppe à
stepanov il est maître de conférences à
l'école pratique des hautes études
spécialiste du chamanisme tout va c'est
celui de sidérer du sud et auteur
notamment de l'ouvragé voyager dans
l'invisible technique chamanique de
l'imagination est préfacé par philippe
des scola aux éditions la découverte
charles stepanov bonjour et merci d'être
avec nous pour ce nouveau débrief du
dock alors pour commencer peut-être une
réaction après le visionnage de ce
documentaire de rts qu'il rejoint les
travaux finalement et les études que
vous avez pu faire
quel aspect important de la culture
chamanique révèle-t-il
bonjour c'est un documentaire qui m'a
beaucoup intéressé parce qu'il a été
tourné dans une région voisine de celle
où moi-même j'ai menées il ya quelques
années mais enquête ethnographique moi
c'était chez les tout valser chez
bouriatte ça m'a bien intéressé parce
que on voit les transformations de
chamanisme qui devient de plus en plus
important marché bouriette c'est
manifeste des lieux des grandes
des grands cérémoniel collectif qui
intéresse toute la population des petits
garçons des petites filles
il ya vraiment un aspect global comme ça
qu'ils nous montrent que ces pratiques
religieuses qui avait été interdite
pendant la période soviétique
non seulement elles sont réapparus
mémène elles deviennent de plus en plus
puissantes elles ont vraiment une
importance sociale incontestable
aujourd'hui alors on va y revenir mais
vous disiez chouval mariachis à
différents chamanisme aujourd'hui dans
le monde alors c'est des peuples
différents les tout va ils parlent une
langue turque
alors que les bouriatte ils parlent une
langue mongole donc c'est des familles
linguistiques différentes
donc du coup dans chacune de ces
sociétés vous allez avoir des esprits et
cosmologie différente puisque c'est
plonger dans l'histoire et dans les
ancêtres de chacun de ces peuples
donc voilà pourquoi il ya forcément des
nuances d'une population à l'autre
ensuite si on compare d'un point de vue
global et d'un en amazonie on a aussi
des traditions chamaniques qui sont
liées à des écosystèmes différents c'est
la forêt tropicale
c'est beaucoup de plantes psychotropes
on n'a pas ça en sibérie naturellement
alors je vous propose de vous plonger de
nous plonger tout de suite dans le vif
du sujet avec cet extrait sur l'île
d'olkhon sur le lac balkanes considéré
par les chamanes comme un lieu sacré une
fois par an depuis 2003 il s'y
réunissent avec des pèlerins cela
s'appelle le taiwan et on va regarder
tout de suite le temps forts de ce
rendez vous le moment fort du rite le
moment où le grand chaman bahir fait
descendre l'esprit principale de l'île
auj
[Musique]
[Rires]
je suis venu à votre taille gan où de
nombreuses personnes se sont rassemblées
bonjour à vous accepter cette offrande
merci j'aimerais vous présenter mon
tuteur c'est lui qui vous a appelé il
s'appelle bahir fils de jean de balle il
est le chef chaman et c'est lui qui nous
guide de la cérémonie d'aujourd'hui en
esprit suis généralement en même schéma
il baignait tout le monde et répond aux
questions alors on vient de voir ces
images finalement pas si évidente que ça
abordé quand on est dans son canapé en
ex en occident alors comment est-ce
qu'on peut définir la culture chaminade
finalement c'est une religion vous avez
employé le mot tout à l'heure c'est du
folklore c'est un art de vivre qu'est ce
que c'est au fond il ya un peu de tout
ça c'est vrai qu'il ya un aspect
religieux puisque il ya l'ensemble du
rapport au monde et à l'invisible qui
inclut dans ses pratiques
mais en même temps vous avez des
systèmes religieux plus officielle qui
coexistent dans les traditions locales
alain plet bouriat hills ont
christianisé depuis plusieurs siècles
donc si on leur demande en général quel
est votre religion
ils vont dire qu'ils sont chrétiens
mieux plus de sud ils vont dire qu'ils
sont bouddhistes
on a beaucoup de systèmes religieux qui
se rencontrent et vous pouvez avoir des
russes aussi de religion chrétienne qui
vont consulter des chamans autochtones
donc ce n'est pas incompatible
du coup ça peut être aussi considéré
plutôt comme une pratique magique qui va
permettre de résoudre des problèmes plus
concret que des grandes questions
métaphysiques qui sont abordés par le
christianisme et le bouddhisme de chaman
suis finalement c'est pas une religion
avec une structure comme on peut le voir
dans la
religion catholique ou encore dans
l'islam et dans le bouddhisme ce n'est
pas ça finalement y'a pas une vraie
structure avec un grand chef qui
chapeauterait tous les chamans du monde
tout à fait il n'ya pas d'unification
institutionnels ça c'est très important
c'est lié au fait que chaque chaman et
bien il fonde sa pratique sur ses
expériences personnelles sur sa
biographie sur des esprits qui l'a vu en
rêve dans son enfance qui sont liées
aussi à ce qu'on lui a raconté sur ses
ancêtres la visite d un c'est très très
importante donc c'est profondément
individualisée comme pratique un chaman
il va acquérir des nouveaux esprits au
cours d'une visite d'une montagne ou
d'une rivière
donc vous avez cette singularité isation
qui est intrinsèque dans le chamanisme
et qui empêche une unification régional
ou mondial
du coup les chamans souvent ils sont en
conflit entre pouvait avoir des guerres
de chaman les uns contre les autres
cela dit on voit des tendances à
l'unification dans certaines régions est
une c'est le cas notamment chez les
bouriatte c'est ce qui est très frappant
dans ce reportage
c'est que on voit que malgré leurs
différences qui sont sous jacente les
chemins ne peuvent faire l'effort de
mener des grands rituels en commun quand
s'associe à un sentiment d'appartenance
id régionale ethnique comme c'est le cas
chez les bouriatte mais bon vous alors
que chez d'autres ethnies
il est absolument impossible d'avoir
plusieurs chaman dans une même pièce
parce que sinon on dit qu'ils vont se
manger l'un l'autre
alors les premiers chaman quand est ce
qu'on les retrouve dans l'histoire du
monde c'est quoi les origines du
chamanisme
alors là c'est pas du tout facile de
répondre à cette question bien sûr
puisqu'il s'agit d'une tradition orale
autant pour le christianisme le
bouddhisme
on va avoir des sources écrites qui nous
permettent de dater l'apparition des
fondateurs la transmission des textes là
autant dans le chamanisme n'est pas
possible puisque les chamans ont été
très longtemps rétif à tout usage de
l'écriture donc on fait des hypothèses
certains chercheurs pensent que ça
serait la religion originelle la
religion qui remonteraient au
paléolithique supérieur qu on pourrait
interpréter l'art des grottes en
occident par exemple en comparant avec
les pratiques des chamans de sibérie
actuellement c'est une hypothèse mais
qui est évidemment impossible à prouver
d'autres au contraire ont souligné qu'il
ya une histoire dans une chemise que le
chamanisme évolué comme toutes les
autres religions qui se transforme qu'il
par exemple il s'est adapté à l empire
de georgie ce camp il peut devenir une
religion d'état il peut au contraire à
se dissoudre se cacher pendant l'époque
soviétique réapparaître à d'autres
moments
donc la question n'est pas facile de
trancher en tout cas beaucoup de
chercheurs comme vous s'intéresse à
cette culture cette culture chamanique
dans le documentaire on entend le
docteur valentina karito va de
l'académie des sciences de russie
depuis le début des années 2000 elle
fait ses recherches dans toutes les
régions de russie où se trouvent des
chamans je vous propose tout de suite de
l'écouter notre objectif était de voir
comment se transforme et comment se
modifier l'activité cérébrale de
l'individu lors d'une séance chamanique
discover the matrix nasco supposions que
leur cerveau fonctionne et peut-être
différemment de celui des gens
ordinaires
alors on vient d'entendre un
interrogations de cette chercheuse
est-ce que vous aussi vous vous êtes
interrogé sur cette facette du chaman à
savoir est ce qu'il aurait un physique
hors norme
quelle est votre réflexion à ce sujet
alors pour les bouriatte voulait tout va
oui les chamans ils ont un physique
différent des gens ordinaires et c'est
ça qui explique leur capacité
extraordinaire c'est ce qui explique le
français concurremment invisible
quelle différence par exemple chez les
bouriatte chez les bouriatte et un
chaman qui était célèbre sur l'île
d'olkhon qu'on voit dans le documentaire
sur le lac baïkal un des indices que
c'était quelqu'un de différent de
l'ordinaire c'est que il avait ce qu'on
appelle un doigt surnuméraires donc sur
une main il avait six doigts au lieu de
cinq
et ça c'est un signe d'élections
chamanique chez pas mal de population de
sibérie ça peut être d'une malformation
quelconque une dort mal placé et donc là
les gens ils voient ça comme lundi ce
que cet homme il a un corps spécial
il a un squelette spécial chez les ja
coûte de sibérie on considère qu' il
peut avoir une cote supplémentaire dans
sa cage thoracique ou bien que il a un
oeil un troisième oeil invisible caché
dans la tête
ensuite est-ce que ça veut dire que nous
scientifiques on doit considérer qu'ils
ont un corps différent pas forcément
et c'est vrai que ça intéresse beaucoup
de chercheurs qui se questionnent est ce
que leur cerveau marque différemment
on a des éléments aujourd'hui justement
sur le fonctionnement
du chaman du cerveau du chaman il n'ya
pas eu d'étude systématique
il n'y a pas eu de résultat qui
permettrait de dire de façon globale les
chamans oui il fonctionne comme ça quand
ils entrent en transe par exemple parce
que là il faudrait leur les obliger à
venir faire un rituel dans un hôpital
avec un irm
or les chamans ils disent moi je peux
pas si j'ai pas mon tambours si j'ai pas
ma forêt autour si je n'ai pas les
arbres je peux pas communiquer avec les
montagnes donc il ya une impossibilité
pratique vous voyez pour mener ce genre
d'étude le chaman
il doit sauter doit courir il doit
chanter et si en dehors du rituel on lui
demande de réciter son champ mais je ne
peux pas parce qu'il ya besoin d'un
contexte rituel cérémoniel qui fait le
qui donne son sens à la performance
du coup ce qu'on a comme études
scientifiques actuellement qui ont fait
un peu de bruit c'est des études sur des
occidentaux qui ont adopté les pratiques
chamaniques par exemple des occidentaux
et des français qui vont en mongolie qui
deviennent chaman qui pratiquent
désormais en france et avec eux oui ils
acceptent d'aller dans à l'hôpital et de
subir un irm ou un
électroencéphalogramme le problème c'est
que c'est un chamanisme occidentalisée
justement qui peut être détaché du
contexte rituel du rapport avec
l'environnement et donc ça nous donne
pas forcément des informations tout à
fait juste sur le chamanisme autochtones
de sibérie ce chamanisme occidental est
ce qu'on peut parler justement de
chamanisme ou alors est-ce que ça se
rapprocherait pas un peu plus de la
méditation quelle est votre réflexion
sur cette arrivée du chamanisme dans nos
cultures occidentales ben c'est un
phénomène qui date depuis pas mal de
temps en fait parce que les russes des
xviiie siècle les invitait à saint
pétersbourg des chamans dans les salons
aristocratiques
aujourd'hui ça se diffuse en dehors des
cercles de l'élite il ya un intérêt de
plus en plus diffus pour le chamanisme
et c'est intéressant en tant que
chercheur parce que ça nous montre qu
est ce que les occidentaux ils ont
pioché dans la soupe chamanique qu'est
ce qui va les intéresser qu est-ce qui
est qu'est-ce qui est finalement
adaptable à une femme d'importation de
même qu'on va importer des ressources
naturelles
déry le gaz le pétrole il importe
maintenant des ressources spirituelles
qu'on met à notre sauce et c'est vrai
que c'est beaucoup plus tournée vers la
méditation vers la quête de soi le
développement personnel
beaucoup plus que les questions très
pragmatique pour lesquels les sibériens
consulter les chamans qui concerne du
bétail qui a disparu
la perte de la chance à la chasse ou
bien en contexte luz urbain trouver un
emploi ou savoir si j'ai choisi la bonne
personne pour me marier alors charles
stepanov on va continuer à se plonger
dans cette culture chamanique c'est tout
à fait passionnant mais avant on fait
une petite pause à tout de suite
et on poursuit ce débrief du doc sur la
culture chamanique dans le sillage du
documentaire devenir chamane avec vous
charles stepanov vous êtes maître de
conférences à l'école pratique des
hautes études spécialistes mais
spécialiste du chamanisme tout bas c'est
celui de sibérie du sud et auteur
notamment de l' ouvrage vous voyagez
dans l'invisible technique chamanique de
l'imagination
préfacé par philippe descola aux
éditions la découverte alors à la fin du
documentaire on peut lire une mention
aujourd'hui aucun caractère
supranational des chamans n'a été trouvé
néanmoins est ce que vous vous avez des
convictions quant aux se casse côté
supra naturel des chamans alors sur le
surnaturel où il le fait que les
sciences occidentales naturaliste ne
trouve pas de phénomènes surnaturels
c'est normal puisqu'elle se définissent
un la science occidentale depuis le
xviiie siècle dans un cadre qui rejette
l'idée qu'il existe des choses
invisibles
alors ça a évolué du côté de la
psychologie 1 sans entrer dans des
histoires newedge ou spiritualiste tout
simplement
si on prend en compte comment fonctionne
le cerveau humain l'esprit humain notre
imagination
c'est une spécificité de notre espèce on
est capable de se projeter dans l'esprit
des autres on serait pas capable de
communiquer d'échanger de partager des
émotions entre humains sans cette
capacité à se projeter dans l'esprit des
autres et on applique aussi aux animaux
pensons à nos animaux de compagnie on
est capable partager des émotions avec
eux vers les sociétés chamanique cd
société qui est temps de cette capacité
pour enrichir notre rapport au monde
notre compréhension des animaux sauvages
également mais ça va plus loin on
considère qu'on peut partager des
émotions avec une rivière avec une
montagne que ces entités du paysage
eh ben on en est dépendant c'est toute
une vision écologique de l'insertion de
l'humain dans son environnement
on en est dépendant et donc c'est
important de comprendre comment elles
nous perçoivent
qu'est-ce qu'on leur fait est ce qu'on
leur fait violence ou pas et est ce
qu'elles peuvent nous punir se fâcher si
on leur fait violence et ça c'est un pic
de se projeter
donc au delà de soi même au delà de la
société humaine
de façon mental alors ils vont appeler
ça une d esprit d âme
on peut parler de subjectivité un d'un
point de vue occidental ou tout
simplement de réponse de l'environnement
par rapport aux actions humaines et ça
de plus en plus en occident on en est
conscient que oui on a intérêt à prendre
en compte les réponses de
l'environnement de la terre par rapport
à nos activités
on en est conscient néanmoins beaucoup
aujourd'hui encore en occident il voit
dans cette culture chamanique davantage
un folklore peut-être en regardant on a
vu tout à l'heure
cet extrait d'un chaman habité par un
esprit et ça nous paraît aujourd'hui
complètement dans nos sociétés
occidentales
finalement on a on a du mal à le
comprendre ça comment vous l'expliquez
oui alors le phénomène il est il est
complexe et c'est vrai qu'on a tendance
à s'arrêter juste sur le moment où le
chaman il est possédé par un esprit
en fait c'est comme on le voit dans le
reportage extrêmement longs la
préparation ça dure plusieurs jours et
vous avez des champs le chant c'est
capital dans le chamanisme alors on peut
appeler ça du folklore on peut aussi
appeler ça de la poésie
les chamans c'est des gens qui sont
capables d'improviser des chants de
louanges envers les esprits de louanges
envers le paysage la montagne qui
décrivent les monts de l'altaï comme un
corps céleste d'un corps qui nourrit les
humains et ils improvisent tous à anvers
donc imaginer comme nous quelqu'un qui
serait capable d'improviser des verts en
alexandrins ça demande une très très
grande maîtrise une maîtrise de la
langue des effets linguistique des
modifications de la syntaxe des
métaphores extrêmement riche à tout ça
en prend rarement en compte 1 en
occident quand on parle de chemise parce
qu'on est braquée sur le moment de la
possession est en fait le champ il
prépare la procession parce que c'est
deschamps qui décrivent le chaman
lui-même sa vie mais aussi ses ancêtres
et qui reproduisent la parole des
ancêtres donc petit à petit le chaman il
laisse parler des voix qui sont pas
juste la sienne danse à travers sa
bouche et il va donner la parole il
reproduit les chants des ancêtres et
petit à petit il ressemble de plus en
plus il se met à imiter de plus en plus
et bien les auteurs des paroles qui
prononce jusqu'à finalement et bien
prêter leur corps à leur esprit les
jambes d'une conception de l'identité
tout à fait vriller riche complexe qui
inclut le mois mais aussi des couches
superposées de génération c'est alors
effectivement vous n'êtes pas le seul
chercheur il ya beaucoup de chercheurs
qui s'intéressent à cette culture
chamanique
au fond pourquoi quel intérêt suscite l
aujourd'hui pour des chercheurs alors
d'une façon générale on a envie de
connaître quand on est anthropologue des
modes de vie des façons de concevoir la
place de l'humain dans la nature
et pour ça va ça implique d'aller faire
des enquêtes de terrain de longue durée
d'apprendre la langue parce que ça ouvre
pour l'imagination le champ des
possibles de se dire que notre façon de
vivre à notre façon de concevoir
l'univers à laquelle on est habitués qui
nous paraît la seule naturel il a en
fait il y en a d'autres qui sont
extrêmement différentes donc là on
al'impression bien d'un univers mental
beaucoup plus large
et puis alors à titre personnel moi je
me suis intéressé en particulier aux
usages de l'imagination
sachant que l'homme c'est cet animal qui
une imagination extraordinaire qui
l'utilisent pour communiquer c'est la
vie sociale elle met en oeuvre cette
imagination et bien les chamans nous
montre des usages de l'imagination très
large qui permet de socialiser les
relations pas seulement avec les humains
mais aussi avec les animaux les plantes
avec les défunts est avec les montagnes
les rivières le paysage en général alors
on en a parlé on l'a vu tout à l'heure
c'est ce fameux état de transe du chaman
comment est-ce qu'on l'expliquent
aujourd'hui alors déjà la notion même de
transe
elle fait un peu tiquer les
anthropologues parce que c'est une façon
occidentale d'expliquer ce qu'on n'a pas
vraiment compris on dit là il devient un
peu fou le chaman iso tikrit ont dit
c'est de latran c'est ce qu'on dit
depuis le xviiie siècle
à partir du moment où les chercheurs ont
appris les langues locales
ils ont étudié ces chants et que
j'évoquais qu'on a compris leur
complexité leur poésie la richesse on
s'est rendu compte que la notion de
français de plus tout à fait suffisantes
on a plutôt une démultiplication de
l'identité une complexification du mois
et ça peut prendre des formes tout à
fait variable suivant les chamans
certains vont se lancer à fond crier
sauter avoir l'air de se transformer
pour d'autres ça va être beaucoup plus
mesurée ça va demeurer un champ avec une
versification extrêmement maîtrisé
est-ce que vous ont peut être moi un
jour on pourrait devenir chamane
ou alors il faut des qualités
particulières alors là les sociétés vont
faire des réponses différentes
les bouriatte convoi dans le reportage
par exemple il considère que pour être
chaman
il faut être un héritier de chaman il
faut avoir des ancêtres donc si vous
n'avez pas d'ancêtres c'est assez
compromis cela dit il est possible que
vous ayez des ancêtres et que vous ne
les connaissez pas donc dans ce cas là
il peut arriver qu'un enfant manifeste
un talent chamanique
et alors on va supposer que il avait d
1,7 mais on les a oubliés
il ya d'autres sociétés dans lesquelles
on considère que oui chacun et un quasi
chaman la différence entre le
spécialiste et le non spécialiste
elle était nue il est possible de passer
au travers donc en gros on va avoir un
chamanisme hiérarchique fondée sur
l'idée de transmission héréditaire avec
des épreuves avec un passage extrêmement
formalisé comme on le voit dans le
reportage avec une gradation va subir
plusieurs consécrations au cours de sa
vie et puis les ailleurs témoins
hiérarchique plus égalitaire où le
chaman et bien il devient chaman
facilement quand il le veut et peut
cesser de l'être quand il veut
d'ailleurs je vous propose de regarder
tout de suite cet extrait c'est le
moment justement où des enfants
participent à une initiation regarde
ça me fait mal ça suffit calme toi voilà
ça va mieux s'acheter
[Musique]
les chaussures sont resserrés pourquoi
tu pleures
non c'est difficile de respirer en
sautant tout le monde est à bout de
souffle calme toi
[Musique]
je rentre à la maison je suis toi le
visage hâlé ça suffit ça suffit on va te
gronder situe au coeur et tu seras
obligé de faire neuf tours de plus des
images assez touchante avec ce petit
garçon qui pleure et puis la sévérité
aussi de cette dame qui lui dit
attention va de gronder il faut être
sage des images finalement assez dure on
n'a pas l'habitude un nom plus en
occident de devoir aujourd'hui ce type
de d'éducation pour autant ça doit
passer par ces moments compliqués aussi
pour les enfants
oui alors ça c'est pas grand chose en
tout cas si on veut devenir chamane mais
il ya beaucoup d'épreuves difficiles et
ça peut se manifester dès l'enfance
mais ça va plutôt être des enfants qui
vont fuir dans la forêt qui vont jeûner
qui vont avaler des objets dangereux des
aiguilles etc qui ont craché du sang il
ya énormément de violence
évidemment dans le chamanisme comment
ils s'expliquent justement ces vieux
parce qu'on est dans un univers qui est
marqué par la prédation les relations
entre les différentes espèces et des
relations de prédateurs et de proies les
bouriatte les autres peuples de sibérie
vivent de l'élevage mais aussi en grande
partie de la chasse c'est quelque chose
de très important dans leurs économies
et donc pour vivre et bien il faut
mettre à mort d'autres êtres vivants
il faut le négocier avec les autres
êtres vivants et il faut s'attendre
aussi soi même en tant qu'être humain à
passer du statut de prédateur
quelquefois à celui de proie mais c'est
une grande différence avec nos sociétés
occidentales dans lesquelles l'humain
c'est essentiellement un prédateur parce
que nous n'avons plus autour de nous des
prédateurs qui peuvent nous manger comme
des loups des ours qui ont disparu
quasiment alors que dans les sociétés de
sibérie et bien il ya des prêts d'hier
il ya le loup il ya l'ours qui sont
extrêmement dangereux qui tue de
nombreuses personnes chaque année
et puis il ya les esprits de la même
manière que les doux et les autres c'est
bien on considère qu'une maladie c'est
causé par un esprit qui vous dévore donc
face à cette violence du monde et bien
les chamans réagissent par de la
violence aussi on n'est pas dans de
l'idéalisme et de la bienveillance comme
on imagine d'un point de vue occidental
qui donne une vision un petit peu
lénifiantes du chamanisme non le
chamanisme mobilise la violence est un
combat contre les mauvais esprits contre
les malédictions les mauvais sort qui
lui doivent être renvoyés à leurs
expéditeurs et pour ça il faut de la
tromperie quelquefois de le des ruses du
des mensonges et puis de la pure
violence ou le chaman doit frapper les
mauvais esprits pour les chasser du
corps du malade alors charles stepanov
pour conclure alors cette culture
chamanique au fond qu'est-ce qu'elle
pourrait apporter à l'occident
aujourd'hui
et puis vous à titre personnel qu'est ce
qu'elle vous a apporté
je pense que c'est l'archi d'horizon
finalement un de s'intéresser aux
cultures chamanique parce que ça nous
montre que notre rapport aux animaux aux
plantes et aux paysages
il pourrait être beaucoup plus riches
finalement on l'a appauvri au cours des
siècles mais il est possible on le voit
avec les chamans de sibérie d'entrer en
communication par le rêve par les chants
avec toutes ces entités
alors c'est pas pour dire qu'il faut se
convertir aux pratiques chamaniques
parce que de toute façon comme on voit
avec les usages chamanique en occident
et ben
il est transformé ces pratiques à sion
transformer des quais lente et qu'elles
sont importés chez nous et et elles
deviennent finalement quelque chose de
occidentale mais plutôt voilà élargir le
champ des possibles ce qui m'a intéressé
finalement c'est de voir des personnes
qui manipulent à la fois la peur la
violence mais aussi de rire hein c'est
quelque chose qu'on en oublie souvent
c'est des gens qui ont énormément
d'humour les chamans et avec qui on
s'amuse beaucoup
merci charles stepanov d'avoir participé
à un autre débrief du dogme je rappelle
que vous êtes maître de conférences à
l'école pratique des hautes études
spécialiste du chamanisme tout-va
celui-ci berry du sud et auteur
notamment de l'ouvragé voyager dans
l'invisible technique chamanique de
l'imagination aux éditions de la
découverte cette émission est à revoir
sur notre site
rt france point tv à découvrir également
en podcast merci pour votre fidélité à
bientôt sur rt france
[Musique]